et dicale trésor au bayern c'est un
titre qui n'a rien à voir avec tintin en
amérique ou encore les sept boules de
cristal le sceptre d'ottokar autant de
titres donnés par hergé aux aventures de
tintin autant d'exploits qui ont donné
l'idée aux inconditionnels de tintin
reporter de créer un musée imaginaire au
centre culturel de la communauté
française de belgique à paris un musée
qui rassemble en quelque sorte les
objets qui ont servi à hergé dans les
différentes histoires qu'il a imaginé
pour tintin pour en savoir plus nous
allons rejoindre tout de suite gérard
holtz qui se trouve lui-même là-bas sur
place avec peut-être en main les sept
boules de cristal ou encore les bijoux
de la castafiore je vois pas pas tout à
fait daniel mais vous n'étiez pas loin
puisqu'on était a été tout près de la
momie de raska rascar capac difficile à
dire
la mamie qu'on retrouve la mobile très
célèbre que l'on retrouve dans les sept
boules de cristal alors d'abord je crois
que pour bien comprendre ce musée
imaginaire de tintin on va demander à
monsieur dulull le directeur du musée de
nous expliquer quel genre d'objet on
retrouve ici
alors c'est une exposition qui a été
conçu en fait par une équipe belge qui
est parti de bruxelles et qui va
circuler dans le monde et une exposition
vraiment à double détente je peux dire
il ya un côté très clin d'oeil qui est
constitué de tas d'objets de maquettes
de reconstitution du monde de 20 ans et
alors il ya une partie extrêmement
importante sérieuse scientifique qui est
la présentation d'objets de collections
privées publiques qui sont des objets de
grande valeur artistique et d'ailleurs
de grande valeur à tous points de vue
alors le clin d'oeil par exemple c'est
ce que vous avez entre les mains ou
c'est ce que j'ai moi dans la poche il
j'ai essayé de sortir
voilà vous allez me dis merci c'est le
clin d'oeil c'est la boîte de crabes qui
apparaît dans l'album
le crabe aux pinces d'or évidemment qui
a été complètement inventée pour le
musée imaginaire voilà ou alors une
petite maquette une petite un petit
moulage du fétiche aaron de bayonne
l'oreille cassée mais on y trouve aussi
le sous marin du professeur tournesol là
la fusée de la lune
enfin il ya toute une série d'objets
comme ça qu'ils ont très très amusant et
qui sont la reconstitution de ce monde
de tintin pour ça on va pas les montrer
pour laisser aux amateurs le soin de
venir ici et de visiter le musée le même
et puis alors ya le deuxième aspect qui
sont les objets véridique qui ont servi
à hergé pour illustrer ses albums
exactement et dont un des objets les
plus spectaculaires si on peut qualifier
comme ça c'est la fameuse grille qui
vient des sept boules de cristal
il ya d'abord les totems là qui viennent
du dahomey ce que l'on retrouve dans
tintin au congo si je ne me trompe
puis il ya cette fameuse momie donc très
célèbre dans le monde entier dont
surtout de ce qui est évidemment un
connaissent un teint puisqu'elle
apparaît dans les sept boules de cristal
comment est ce que il est venu à l'idée
dé rejet de l'utiliser cette nouvelle
aile arrière j'ai je crois je crois si
l'on en croit l'histoire était chez le
collectionneur à qui appartient cette
cette pièce qui s'appelle compte de grun
belge et voyant la momie il a été
absolument prix si on veut par
l'atmosphère et ça a commencé son cinéma
je dirais a commencé à jouer à partir de
là il a imaginé toute une histoire
fabuleuse qui est les sept boules de
cristal
vient alors le musée imaginaire de
tintin est ouvert jusqu'en alors
jusqu'au 4 janvier peut-être un peu plus
tard nous l'espérons s'est ouvert tous
les jours sauf le lundi et les enfants
sont absolument accueillis gratuitement
nous demandons simplement aux parents de
contribuer un petit peu l'opération bon
alors merci monsieur de lui maintenant
on va passer aux internes aux fils et
aux teintes analogue avec d'abord ses
statuettes que costas notre cameraman de
l'équipe hf qui a fait des prodiges ici
puisqu'ils se sont installés en trois
quarts d'heure de temps dans ce musée
imaginaire avec ses statuettes qui
viennent d'afrique et que l'on retrouve
dans l'appartement dans le salon de
marque charlet qui est le
l'explorateur des sept boules de cristal
alors tintane hologue éminent christian
personas vous êtes avocat dans la vie et
vous êtes féru de tintin thierry qui est
à côté de lui onze ans et demi qui lui
aussi est féru de tintin puisqu'il est
venu visiter l'exposition
alors tous les deux vous aller dialoguer
autour de marc charlet par exemple alors
je vous laisse je demander à thierry
d'abord est ce qui ce qui est marc
charlet expliqué marc charles s éteint
c'est un explorateur qui est dans une
dent dans son salon au moment où tintin
la prévenue tintin a prévenu qu' il va
être il risque d'être attaqué par la
momie du rascar capac tels les autres
membres de l'expédition en fait il
faisait partie d'une expédition qu'on
appelle exigences envers sa retraite et
tous les membres y en a 700 versa lutte
qui est le capitaine de l'explosif de
l'expédition est également l'aubépin
bergamote ornais clermont charlet et
c'est donc lui qui est charles ix et
hornec et conservateur du musée que l'on
voit également donc tous ces personnages
vont être atteints par cette boule qui m
envoyer les sept boules de cristal et
dans ce cristal dans cette boule il va y
avoir un produit qui va les mettre dans
un état de léthargie et à la suite des
aventures à la suite des aventures de de
tintin qui vont se rendre ensuite dans
le temple du soleil qui hélas la suite
ils vont justement trouvé le temple du
soleil et la personne qui torturait les
statuettes je vous interromps un petit
peu parce que évidemment comme
d'habitude le temps passant on va
simplement peut-être demander à thierry
d'essayer de vous coller puisque vous
êtes vous docteur reste un vous
connaissez pratiquement tous dans tintin
des plaques minéralogiques aux numéros
des maisons gros numéros des rues série
est ce que tu pourrais poser une
question qui est pour essayer de le
coller sur un album que tu connais
d'accord quoi et là je connais le trésor
de rackham le rouge
bon alors posé une question à propos du
trésor à quelques ailes momo se passe
quand le sous marin de tintin les free
dans les salles
oui et bien que ce qui se passe à ce
moment là bas ce moment là le sous marin
aidant les ags une teinte un appui sur
le petit bouton rouge qui était à gauche
ce qui va dégager de la fumée c'est bien
que le capitaine et tournesol vont aller
sur un bateau et avec un grappin vont
arriver à sortir tata ou voilà on va
laisser des spécialistes et les fanas de
tintin entre eux avec gérard holz merci
de ce petit visite au musée imaginaire
de tintin je suppose que tous les
amateurs iront sans tarder à cette
exposition